simon de carvalho président de
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
on sur rt france alors quel regard
portez vous sur les conclusions avancées
par ce nouveau rapport pour nous c'est
important de savoir effectivement
l'origine de l'incendié
néanmoins ça reste un détail suisse
appartiennent à l'entreprise grisolles
gay garant de la sécurité de ses
produits
il est responsable c'est important pour
la sécurité des riverains et pour la
sécurité des deux ouvriers pour qu'ils
sont très angoissés en tout cas je parle
pour les riverains qui habitent vraiment
plus proche de cette usine de savoir
d'où est parti l'incendié pour axa re ça
se reproduise que l'industriel maîtrise
son son outil c'est très important
maintenant nous on savait pas ce que ça
te fait un an qu'on travaille sur le
dossier que toute façon cette cesse on a
de grands doutes pense pense beaucoup
que ça vient de chez lubrizol
on est encore un an après elle
effectivement sur des probabilités nous
ce qui compte c'est que le prix soit
condamné lourdement ce sont ces produits
qui ont brûlé son assureur la prévenue
il est pénalement responsable
et c'est bien ils nous en ont
effectivement les dirigeants de lubrizol
ainsi que les personnes de la dréal qui
a pu donc pas vu venir la catastrophe
alors l'assureur lui l'avait informée
avait informé les dirigeants de la
lisons n'est malheureusement pas très
bonnes et mines question aussi sur le
suivi sanitaire des riverains plus d'un
an après les faits il en est où ce suivi
nous espérons un rendez vous très
prochainement avec santé publique france
pour pouvoir mettre en place suivi
sanitaire
donc pour le moment nous avons juste eu
un petit questionnaire de santé
c'est terrible mais c'est comme ça
questionnaire de santé après cette prise
sur la tête effectivement dix mille
tonnes quasiment 2 pourquoi nos produits
toxiques cancérigènes les produits
hautement dangereux et puis aujourd'hui
est bien plus d'un an après on a répondu
qu'à ce petit questionnaire donc
normalement je l'espère
courant janvier last sinistrés libre
isole va voir santé publique france pour
essayer de mettre en place rapidement
merci pour votre réaction et pardon pour
cette mauvaise connexion simon de
carvalho président de l'association des
sinistrés de lubrizol